salut les épicurieuses et les epicurieux
vous connaissez sans doute cette immense
tube d'Orelsan la terre est ronde et
bien elle n'a pas tort on sait depuis
l'Antiquité que notre planète est de
forme plus ou moins sphérique et
pourtant certains en doutent allez je
vous apporte quelques preuves que la
terre est bien ronde des preuves qui
reposent sur des observations que vous
pouvez faire vous-même allez ça tourne
mon fond je sais que la terre est ronde
d'abord un peu l'histoire l'idée que la
terre est ronde n'est pas nouvelle le
mathématicien Greg Pythagore celui du
théorème le supposait déjà 5 siècles
avant Jésus-Christ sans toutefois être
en mesure de le prouver deux autres
Grecs Aristote puis Ératosthène
parviendront finalement à le démontrer
plus de 3 siècles avant notre ère pour
le prouver ce dernier atostens a eu
l'idée de planter deux bâtons à des
endroits très éloignés l'un plus au nord
que l'autre puis il a mesuré leur ombre
projeté à la même heure si la terre
avait été plate ses ombres auraient été
strictement
identiques or ce n'est pas le cas celle
plus au nord était plus longue ce
phénomène ne peut s'expliquer que par la
rotondité de la Terre et pourtant
aujourd'hui encore certains sont
persuadés que la terre est plate et
qu'on leur ment tenez en 2020 certains
Mike hugs a perdu la vie en voulant en
apporter la preuve il a péri aux
commandes d'une refuser qu'il avait
construit dans son garage il voulait
prendre des photos de la terre à 1500
mètres d'altitude pour démontrer qu'elle
était parfaitement plate donc
heureusement la plupart des platistes
c'est le nom qu'on leur donne sont plus
terre à terre
certains avancent que si la terre était
ronde les habitants de l'hémisphère sud
auraient la tête en bas et tomberait
dans le vide franchement ça tient pas
debout en effet quel que soit le lieu où
l'on se trouve sur terre nos deux pieds
sont parfaitement collés au plancher des
vaches ceci grâce à une force
fondamentale la gravité cette force
attire tous les objets vers le centre de
la Terre nous y compris si la terre
était plate la gravité ne produirait pas
du tout les mêmes effets sur les objets
allez on va faire un peu de
science-fiction imaginons que notre
planète se présente sous la forme d'un
disque comme ce vieux 33 tours au-dessus
duquel je vais placer un fil à plomb si
la terre était plate donc le centre de
gravité se trouverait au centre du
disque ici une plante serait attirer
dans cette direction sauf qu'en fonction
de l'endroit où on se trouve sur le
disque le fil serait plus ou moins
incliné à l'exception bien sûr à la
plomb du centre du disque
imaginez ce que ça donnerait pour nous
les humains on vivrait pencher et de
plus en plus au fur et à mesure que l'on
s'éloignerait du centre le même
phénomène se produirait avec les arbres
les monuments ce n'est évidemment pas le
cas comme la terre est une sphère nous
sommes toujours à la même distance de
son centre et la force de gravité
s'exerce toujours de la même manière
perpendiculaire au sol c'est ce qui nous
permet de tenir debout et qui fait qu'un
objet tombe toujours à la verticale
comme notre fameux fil à plomb
c'est le physicien Isaac Newton qui a
mis ce phénomène en évidence au XVIIe
siècle la légende veut qu'il ait eu la
révélation en observant
une pomme tombée d'un arbre
elle est bien celle-ci aussi
[Musique]
la deuxième observation simple qui
prouve la retournité de la terre est
bien plus ancienne on la doit aux
philosophes grecs Aristote qui a été le
premier à la réaliser trois siècles et
demi avant Jésus-Christ pour y parvenir
il a observé le ciel à l'occasion d'une
éclipse de lune ce phénomène se produit
lorsque la terre vient se placer pile
poil entre le Soleil et la Lune et que
remarque Aristote et bien il constate
que l'ombre de la Terre recouvre
progressivement la surface lunaire et
surtout que cette ombre est arrondi cet
arc de cercle selon lui est bien la
preuve que la Terre a une forme
sphérique et non pas plate si la terre
était plate voilà ce que ça donnerait
or personne n'a jamais vu ça
une autre observation facile à réaliser
lorsque vous vous promenez en bord de
mer et que vous regardez les bateaux
s'éloignés de la côte plus un navire fil
vers le large plus sa taille diminue
jusqu'au moment où il finit par
disparaître complètement ce n'est pas
une question d'acuité visuelle même avec
la lunette la plus puissante du monde
il y a un moment où le bateau finit par
disparaître
à cause de la courbure de la terre au
niveau de la mer l'horizon se trouve à
environ 5 km pour un homme le taille
moyenne la courbure notre planète nous
empêche de voir au-delà tenez la
prochaine fois vous vous baladez en bord
de mer observez ce qui se passe au
moment où le bateau franchit la ligne
d'horizon c'est toujours l'avant du
navire qui disparaît en premier comme si
celui-ci longeait vers l'avant si la
terre était plate avec une longue vue on
pourrait le suivre infiniment plus
longtemps
je vais utiliser cette lampe pour
symboliser le soleil
si la terre était plate comme ce
planisphère toute la planète serait
éclairée en même temps alors certes le
soleil serait plus ou moins haut en
fonction de l'endroit où on se trouve
mais dès l'instant où le soleil
franchirait la ligne d'horizon il ferait
jour partout au même moment jour nuit
jour nuit jour nuit si la terre était
plate le soleil se lèverait à la même
heure pour tout le monde et en toute
logique il se coucherait aussi à la même
heure pour tout le monde or vous le
savez ce n'est pas ce qui se passe
lorsqu'il est 9h du matin à Paris par
exemple et qu'il fait jour à New York il
n'est que 4 heures du matin et il fait
encore nuit inversement quelques heures
plus tard alors qu'il est 18h à New York
qu'il fait encore jour et bien il est
23h à Paris et il fait nuit c'est bien
la preuve que la terre tourne sur
elle-même un tour en 24 heures et
qu'elle est ronde
si vous doutez encore je vous invite
maintenant à lever les yeux au ciel
quand il fait nuit avec un télescope
vous pointez mars ou Saturne et là que
vous voyez vous deux planètes rondes
comme toutes les planètes connues dans
l'univers alors je sais certains diront
qu'il s'agit de disques et pas de sphère
et bien en poursuivant l'observation
vous constatez que des détails défilent
à la surface ils apparaissent d'un côté
et disparaissent de l'autre c'est donc
bien la preuve que ces planètes sont
sphériques du coup si nos voisines sont
sphériques pourquoi la Terre serait-elle
plate allez on va finir en beauté
l'ultime preuve de la rotondité de la
Terre a été fournie par la mission
Apollo 17 en 1972 il s'agit de la toute
première photo de la terre complète
prise depuis l'espace les Américains
l'ont surnommé Blue Marble la Bible
[Musique]
pas de doute notre terre est bien ronde
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu que vous y voyez plus clair que vous
disposez de tous les arguments pour
défendre la retondité de la terre je
vous dis à très bientôt en attendant si
ce n'est pas déjà fait je vous invite à
vous abonner à la chaîne epicurio il n'y
a rien de plus encourageant pour nous
que de voir cette belle communauté
d'épicurieuse et d'épicurieuse s'étoffer
[Musique]